so moving on to the Madeleine McCann
case the first thing upon watching the
most recent Netflix series and I'm sure
lots of people who are listening will
have seen it as well the first thing
that struck me was how I don't to say
bungled but how oddly the case was dealt
with upon immediate investigation in
terms of the crime scene in terms of
everything else that was that was
probably the most one of the most
shocking things I got out of it when you
you mentioned the crime scene and I
guess you're thinking about the accounts
which I obviously also although we were
interviewed for the series we weren't
part of it in the Netflix series though
we are in each episode so we have worked
it closely and we found that virtually
everything and I mean 99.9% was accurate
so far as we know and we I think
ourselves and in the show's discuss what
happened in the crime scene woman woman
goes into apartment
apparently finds child missing goes out
makes a terrible cry all their
considerably large party now no 10
people the other doctors and their
friends come come rushing to the
apartment they're all they're all
trampling around the apartment and and
then they called the police are called
when the police eventually arrive they
come in they trample around the
apartment at some point dogs come into
their search dogs come into the
apartment and that is completely
contrary to what the police like the way
the police like a crime scene to be
handled in what they called the golden
are the first are that is why when one
sees for instance a shooting in the
street you see on the news nightly
scenes in which the police have put up
tapes and stopped people stopped the
people trampling over the golden
evidence the first evidence the evidence
was there
and that wasn't done in this case but
you talked about the possible thundering
and so on
well that was thundering at some stage
in the investigation but it does is
there's also a thing called human nature
when the police were called to the
apartment they thought there was a
little girl who was missing and she
wandered off what had happen where was
she
maybe she's going to turn out in turn up
in D in the wardrobe and under the bed
maybe she's there really maybe she's
just hiding from mommy and daddy and of
course the none of that food proved to
be the case but during that time people
had not were not thinking of the crime
of possible crime they they weren't
thinking of something sinister that
wouldn't be solved for more than a
decade they were just trying to find
that little girl who might be here so
there was a reason and a sort of a
justification for why the golden r was
ignored I suppose it's a short-term pain
for a long-term gain that you need to
make a judgment on upon the beginning of
the case right there you need to they
want to think oh well if she is in here
somewhere or if it's not a crime we need
to work more expeditiously rather than
delicately but obviously the benefit of
hindsight is is fantastic and looking
back you say well why didn't they just
close the other okay so I think I think
what you say is true but absolutely it
was a resource and division of labour
issue as well but the first Portuguese
police office to arrive on the scene or
the sort of local beat cops who you know
would not necessarily have been all that
clued in to the idea of crime scene
preservation etc whereas immediately an
hour later when the more senior
detectives arrived they were themselves
horrified by this you know tarnishing of
the of the evidence by having all these
people trample it you know they were
none too pleased with their colleagues
that this had happened and I think that
was then compounded the Portuguese
police's initial
mistakes in terms of the crime scene or
then compounded by two other things one
they fail to clear the parents of
involvement
you know usually in cases like this it
is always a family member who you look
at first and in in the words of the the
policeman who was responsible for
reviewing this case and deciding you
know it wasn't handled very well he
thought that they had failed to clear
the clear the ground in front of them
and that's that's an important mistake
that should have been addressed very
early on instead it festered and the
second thing was the involvement of the
british police you know you had a crime
taking a crime or an abduction or a
missing child taking place in portugal
but she's a british child
so therefore the parents who don't speak
the language are immediately reaching
out for all the support they can get and
that's coming back at them in terms of
multiple police agencies all wanting to
help all wanting to get their Pacha no
we all wanted to be the hero and that
also didn't play well it felt to the
portuguese like the Brits were trampling
all over them and being a colonial power
and being arrogant and and the
Portuguese themselves became very
suspicious what are all these you know
British police officers doing and we're
having for actually having their their
British police colleagues followed so so
the bad relationship again didn't help
in any attempt to find Matt on so the
British thought that the Portuguese were
living in the Stone Age in the sense
that they weren't computerised in the
way the people from when Scotland Yard
we eventually became a vote or just the
police that were sent out on the A's on
the first from England they saw all the
you know cards in boxes and and it's a
tent temporary headquarters with a lot
of paperwork and so on and people and
guys typing with two fingers on on on
old typewriters that's that's not how it
happens that pretty headquarters in
England anymore and so
there grew a feeling that the Portuguese
felt as though they were being at a
certain level thought they were being
treated as though they were from the
third world
[Music]
you